with me now is the shadow Minister for
public health Andrew Gwynn good to talk
to you Mr Gwen are you going to be doing
any volunteering today I am actually
straight after this I'm going down into
the tame Valley in Denton with the
friends of the tame Valley and we're
doing a big uh litter pick in our
country Park and I'm looking forward to
it even though it's drizzling oh well
hopefully the sun will shine uh what did
you feel about the weekend you were at
the coronation did you feel it was an
example of of everything that's best
about Britain or was it a colossal waste
of money oh I loved it and anything that
brings people together makes us feel
good makes us happy
is greater watch the coronation uh
concert on the TV last night and that
was fantastic but what a privilege and
an honor it was to be one of just a very
small number of Labor MPS that were
successful in the ballot to actually
physically be in the Abbey for that
historic moment it's something that I
will cherish for the rest of my life
what about what was going on outside the
Abbey there was of course quite a number
of people arrested not far from from The
Abbey what did you think of the reports
of the police in did you feel it was
proportionate because uh labor Sadiq
Khan has questions certainly
I mean obviously I can't comment on
specific incidents because I don't know
the circumstances behind that and I
would hope that the police use their
powers uh appropriately uh time will
tell there look I voted against the
public order
um act I thought it was disproportionate
in terms of the powers it gives uh to
Authority
um people have a right to express a
different view a different opinion and
they also have the right to offend as
well I actually think the thousands of
people that crowded the Streets of
London would have drowned out any
protests anywhere anyway because people
were there to celebrate a historic event
for our country that brought most people
together in celebration waving flags
cheering being happy that would have
been the appropriate response to drown
out those that wanted to protest rather
than maybe uh heavy-handed tactics that
uh some are suggesting May have taken
place you voted against the public order
act do you think labor should then
repeal the legislation if labor get into
Power well I think we have to look very
closely at this legislation because it's
not just about the right to protest it's
also got
um fundamental issues with the right to
strike as well that we need to take a
very clear look at so uh I think that
the next Labor government will look very
carefully at this piece of legislation
but looking carefully at it doesn't
doesn't mean anything does it it doesn't
mean you're going to reverse it well we
need to see how it's working uh and if
it's not working in the way that the
government says it's intended to work
then that's something that needs
addressing uh but obviously
um what happened over the coronation
weekend the police will investigate and
no doubt report back to the mayor of
London
onto GPS you're the shadow Minister for
public health the conservatives making a
big announcement today about
improvements for GP surgeries in England
money to help uh with with the nuts and
bolts of answering systems with with
people on receptions trying to to stop
that 8 AM Scramble for appointments do
you welcome these plans
well insofar as they go yes but the way
the government's announced it is that
this is going to be a revolutionary
transformation of of primary care
services and yet they're absolutely
nothing in this announcement that will
train more doctors that will enable
patients to choose a face-to-face
appointment all that will bring back the
family doctor it's a very shallow offer
um yes we can make improvements to
technology we can upskill the
receptionists to be able to triage more
appropriately but fundamentally we need
a proper transformation of primary care
utilizing
um far better the community pharmacies
allowing pharmacists to be able to
prescribe a lot more treatments without
you going to see a doctor being able to
uh perform uh certain consultations and
certain tests that they aren't able to
do that would be truly transformational
alongside the long-term change that is
really needed and that is to train more
doctors and we are committed and we've
said to the government pinch our ideas
we are committed to training seven and a
half thousand new GPS and that would be
paid for by abolishing the non-dom tax
status we've been very clear and upfront
that unless you increase the number of
GPS these issues are just sticking
plasters
uh just one final thought before before
you leave us on the local elections um
obviously a good set of results for
labor but some would say you know it
should have been a great deal better the
conservative is not in a great position
at the moment seems like half the
country is almost on strike the
economies had huge issues over the last
six months how do you feel about about
the fact that if you extrapolate these
results out one analysts say you're up
just five points from 2019 not much up
from 2022.
shouldn't labor have done a great deal
better than they did at these local
elections well actually on the national
equivalent vote share we would have had
a ten and a half percent swing compared
to the 2019 general election don't you
to get together phenomenal starting
point and certainly in many of the
Battleground seats that that also uh
when transposed over the electoral map
equate to Marginal seats we have to win
to form a labor government the swing was
even bigger so I'm very optimistic look
it's not job done it's not job done
until the day after the next general
election but the fact that we are now
talking positively about the prospect of
a labor government at the next election
when only two years ago we faced one of
our worst defeats ever I think is a
testament to how kirst armor has moved
the labor party in the voters
perceptions has brought us back into the
game and uh you know we we are all
things being fair and proportionate we
are now in the race for the next general
election and that commentators like
yourself are very seriously talking up
the prospects that labor is on the verge
of government that's down to kirstama
it's down to the work he's put in so far
and now we've got to put Flesh on the
bones with policies building on those
missions that care has already announced
so that at the next general election
there is a very clear offer from the
labor party that the country can get the
change that they are so desperately
crying out for okay Andrew Quinn for
Labor unsurprisingly uh thanks very much
thank you